hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stick shift um I was
heavily debating whether I should make a
video about this game uh for one reason
I'm trying to keep it together this game
is about your relationship with your car
is about the easiest way that I could
say it so I'm gonna start it and you're
gonna immediately see what I'm talking
about bear with me I'm trying to keep it
together so start it and then you'd
literally
little jack up your car and shift into
here is it's called steak Jim anyway
time it's only fine don't worry about it
it's on it wasn't fine cuz this is a fun
game it might be moderately etiquette oh
[__]
god dammit I didn't mean to do that I
apologize my bad let's try again here
sorry let me crank my yank back up into
gear there we go
[__] that wall that's a good ship right
there you gotta get it in sync with him
here we go ah I miss my gear
you tried homewards ahead I'm sorry I'm
not good at this I don't know why I'm
not good at it I'm trying my best
now we're gonna get this all right get
this oh this feels weird but somehow
enjoying myself art cap hop hop come on
down there we go
now I gotta go we get to here don't
worry I got it
yeah uh-huh what is with your eyes bear
what is with your eyes oh my god where
are you driving why are you driving oh
boy oh you got me
no let me try one more time officer Oh
game over man game over oh man what does
that mean what does that mean
mmm what what does that mean what am i
doing
what what what am i how long it's gonna
be until I can play again is that oh my
god are you kidding me oh my god that's
a long I need to play that's all you
watch me to wait til I can play again oh
man that's amazing
oh but I'm gonna beat the system here
don't worry about me I got this sorry
oof okay alright so if this looks weird
it's the same game trust me it's the
same game um what I had to do is I had
to go to the website and download a
separate version of the game that's
bundled in this pack with two other
games that are totally inappropriate for
you guys to watch don't worry about it
not that stick-shift
is appropriate would just bear with me
on this one there's apparently an
updated new and improved version of the
game that's gonna be better I don't know
how it's gonna be better but it's gonna
be better
alright yeah there we go oh that is that
is that is that is definitely better
yeah the controls are just much more
smooth
his the textures on his face are just
wait no I am well there we go
that's what I was hoping for yeah what
do you think into the bottom of this
we're gonna beat this game I'm gonna
ship correctly so die man I'm really
whaling my mouse on this one I'm
flinging it Harden
don't worry here we go here we go here
we go
yeah oh god why does that take so much
there we go
okay get those headlights and demons
inside you shooting out of your eyeballs
something you can pleasure your car the
maximum efficiency I mean it's perfectly
normal
I'm renaming this let's play to how to
drive a stick shift because this is
purely an educational video and there's
nothing weird about it in any capacity
so you
totally fine Oh Miriam oh whoa whatever
we going down where are we going in this
guy's having a trip oh god damn it
Oh [__] oh god damn it I'm really
trying here ah man
oh no not again okay so I looked it up
and apparently that the police pulling
you over is one separate ending and if I
hadn't have kissed my way to ten hours I
would be able to play it again on the
first game that I downloaded so I've got
about eight minutes left
dominant I'm gonna try the other games
what could happen what's the worst
what's the worst thing it'd happen the
ass look promising
oh man is this a game oh god is that a
corn dog or a popsicle oh geez
oh yeah nope nah no no I ain't doing it
nope nope nope nope
okay all right woo all right woo all
right woo all right woo all right woo
okay oh let me just wink oh god what are
we doing okay ah okay this is normal
what if you doing why are we shaking
hands okay okay it's back I brushed my
teeth because I'm healthy and I needed
to wash my mouth now I'm supposed to
sound like you know wash my dirty mouth
out but just came across really weird uh
okay anyway alright so apparently the
endings are randomly generated
occasionally it'll just stop you at the
other thing but here we go alright
have a great time play the game video
games are fun everybody all right here
we go now we're talking
hopefully no one's gonna stop this
Joyride this time hopefully something's
gonna happen I don't know what but
something's gonna happen
oh oh god damn it twice in a row mother
humping humper [__] am I gonna wait to
try again
you goddamn [__] right I am son of a
[__] okay we're back for one more go
and at this point I'm pretty much an
expert at this game so don't worry as I
expertly speed my way through this stick
shifting mastery let me show you how
it's done
oh hey okay
come on [__] [__] oh this is the most
[__] I've ever seen in my life
that's [__]
that's [__] it knows it [__]
that's [__] yeah I'm gonna wait yeah
I'll wait I'll [__] wait [__]
pocket one bingo Bongo okay apparently
we're back all right here we go again
boo-boo rrrrrr rrrrrr
you can't be kidding me you've got to be
kidding me you've got to be kidding me
well that didn't work out for me for
some reason either I was doing something
very wrong and I don't think I was or
random number generation was being very
unkind to me I'm not sure which is which
but apparently it didn't want me to
finish and more ways than one but it
didn't want me to finish the game so
that's all I've got for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
all right I'm back it's another day it's
literally 24 hours after I tried the
first one and I'm gonna try this again
because I got nothing but free time on
my answer let's try to jack off car why
don't we
this is what I do for fun in my spare
time so I look it up and there actually
is about a 50% chance between getting
the cop ending and the happy ending if
you know what I mean so I've just been
incredibly unlucky good for me that's
not used to in my life you also may have
noticed that I even got a different
camera in the mean time it's been that
long
here we go all right it's big time now I
got headlight eyes and I'm swirling
around I don't think it's a good idea
that I'm just spinning my car in a donut
in whatever Street I'm going to but hey
here's no open no cops are gonna show
whoa oh okay I can't [__] this one up oh
I can't [__] it up it better not stall
out baby here we go oh yes I went into
warp-drive I made the jump to hyperspace
um chicken head I'm jerking this car so
gasps ha there are certain things you
don't ever expect to exclaim at the top
of your lungs so that your neighbors
question you even more than they have in
the past but I don't give a [__] oh hey
I didn't even notice that hey six gear
am I ready to do that go have enough
juice back yeah I don't know what
happened but my squid oh god I'm
blacking out I'm wiping out oh jeez did
I want that I finally won did I beat the
odds ill oh god why is that like that
that is no good well God wise got a drip
foot either way that's ant a stick shift
and other inappropriate games I played
or perfectly appropriate I'm not gonna
judge it's a freakin Internet it's a
wasteland of born and weird fetishes so
Who am I to say that you can't love a
car so anyway I don't know what I'm
trying to say but either way that's the
end of this game and that's the end of
this video so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below or don't
use always good with me
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh God so uh how many balls can actually
fit in here I can't stop adding balls
I'm at a loss for words